[Music]
foreign
we are back and welcome back to Hannity
in the great state of Pennsylvania Dr
Amendment Oz is with us
and joining us now former speaker of the
house and Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich is with us
for people at home that's new that's not
a boo okay okay uh Senator Tom Cotton
from the great state of Arkansas is here
Senator Tim Scott from the great state
of South Carolina is with us
I don't want to get ahead of myself but
I could see two potential presidential
candidates down the road I'm just
guessing you never know
just throwing that out there
thank you all for being with us you know
you're running your own re-election
round absolutely you I predict you win
by 12. so I'm glad you're here but
you you made it a priority to help
Herschel to help Dr Oz and Lindsey
Graham said something the other night
that people in South Carolina are tired
of having their votes canceled out by
these radical liberal Senators
absolutely there's no doubt about it
when you think about the most important
issues to Americans inflation Biden has
provided the American people with a pay
cut 18 consecutive months with inflation
outpacing wage increases and in York
Pennsylvania we're going to send a
message to All America elect
monster oh it's got to start here
without any questions
John
I can't even believe it think about what
you said during your amazing monologue
a person puts a shotgun in a man's chest
an innocent man imagine it being
a white Republican
putting the shotgun you scare me now in
the chest
I'll go back there okay we go to church
together we actually do can you imagine
the media frenzy around that issue
can you imagine the having a president
who says nothing on that the national
media silent the vice president silent
why because they care more about the
issue
and the people living in impoverished
areas where I come from they out the
single mothers trapped in their houses
at night praying for daylight so they
can go outside because they're afraid of
the crime
driving throughout this nation we need a
common sense conservative from
Pennsylvania to bring home the majority
by the way
for the record
Senator Scott was not kidding we
actually have the same Pastor uh he
introduced me to him and he's been has
had such a great impact on my life and I
appreciate you as the friend that you
are great friends Senator cotton you're
up from Arkansas you know what I'm glad
you're here this is important to the
country
when you look at when you compare and
contrast fetterman and Dr Oz that you
can't have a bigger Choice election
than this
it really couldn't be a bigger Choice
election Sean and I got to tell you that
control of the senate in Washington runs
through Pennsylvania we have to elect Dr
Oz
to put the brakes unbinds radical
ideological agenda let's just take the
energy issue Sean Dr Oz and I were out
on a natural gas pad in Western
Pennsylvania a couple days ago with
hard-working pennsylvanians who are
getting God's resources out of the
ground for the benefit of America and
the rest of the world the thing about
the issues that you care about do you
care about high paying good quality jobs
for thousands of Pennsylvania families
you've got that do you care about
lowering inflation lowering the cost of
your utility bills then Pennsylvania can
do that for us as well do you care about
supporting our friends and partners
around the world wouldn't it be better
if our friends in Europe had
Pennsylvania gas as opposed to Russian
gas
and if you
or if you're concerned about our
environment isn't it better for us to be
using good clean burning Pennsylvania
natural gas and having third world coal
dug up with the worst cotton with the
worst kinds of practices all around the
world yet
John fetterman as you saw he would ban
hydraulic fracturing the most advanced
Innovative environmentally friendly way
to get that natural gas out of the
ground Dr Oz will be a champion for
Pennsylvania's energy industry he will
prevent the Democrats from forbidding it
and he will promote it
um
for those of you that may not know in
the crowd uh I first met Newt Gingrich
in a holiday in room in 1990 I was a
local host in Alabama and then I got a
job offer in Atlanta where you were and
I was the emcee the night that he became
Speaker of the House in 1994 it was the
honor of my life
and he's one of my dearest closest
friends so you're one of the smartest
political strategist I've ever met and
you have been defining the closing
arguments of this election
explain
okay it's not complicated
if you like inflation eating up your
paycheck you ought to vote Democrat if
you like having your 401k collapse so
you can't afford to retire you ought to
vote Democrat if you think having a guy
Run for the Senate who voted 25 times
to release a murderer when the other
four members of the parole board voted
no the only person to vote for these 25
murderers was Federal now if you think
that's a good idea and Philadelphia
doesn't have enough crime and Pittsburgh
doesn't have enough crime you ought to
vote Democrat because they're going to
make sure you get more they want to give
you more of the wrong thing and less of
the right thing so it's not this is not
a complicated election this is a
straightforward election of having every
American look at the world around them
and make a simple decision you want to
keep going down this road or not one
last thing
I've I've known as for many years
I knew him back when he was already an
Eagles fan which I have to say
anyway hold on one can only go so far
but he may have lost in votes in
Pittsburgh oh I I think any Pennsylvania
team is acceptable at this point but I
know that he went to medical school in
Pennsylvania he went to business school
in Pennsylvania he grew up in the
Philadelphia suburbs and like everything
else about fetterman's campaign the
attack on Oz was just plain a lie
fetterman cannot tell the truth because
if he's going to tell the truth he might
as well get off the ballot
let me highlight one thing
I touched on it earlier but it's rare
that I'm in a group and we do a lot of
gatherings like this just if you don't
mind put your hands up if your life has
been touched by Fentanyl
so you see how many hands go up now
here's the part that hurts me I'm a
doctor I've dealt in addiction for many
many years
and I understand how challenging it is
to come back from that abyss of darkness
when John Federman says he wants to
legalize all drugs decriminalize all
drugs when he wants to create heroin
injection sites and no one wants it in
their neighborhood because they know it
brings crime it's devastating to
communities and then when he says he
wants an open border because he wants
more workers and he wants Sanctuary
cities so our governments can't work you
know Municipal and federal governments
can't work together you build what we
have now in Pennsylvania a a rabid
illness that is taking over all of our
youth and we haven't done anything about
it because we're following John
federman's and people like his lead I
think addiction is probably big in South
Carolina right yeah I mean think about
the issue 107
000 Americans have lost their lives Plus
because our borders are open we need to
build a wall to stop that fitting off
from walking across
we have an opportunity
we have an opportunity to restore sanity
to this country by controlling our
borders every single County in America
every single County in Pennsylvania is a
border County because we're all
experiencing illegal immigration
Fentanyl and National Security risk
because of that southern border being
open so they may ask you if I can a
question for everybody
the reason this race I think is where it
is is because the Democratic party has
been pouring money into Pennsylvania I
just learned before I walked on the
stage here we're expecting another 10
million dollars coming against us and
it's a panic move because they know
they're in trouble and they're pulling
in money from Every Which Way that's why
it is vital vital that we have the
support if I can tell the truth about
John fetterman more than he lies about
me we've got this race and I think
you've all been there
[Applause]
it's very simple if you want to keep
murderers in prison and you want to keep
John fetterman on his parents allowance
go to doctoroz.com
and with that we'll take a quick break
we'll have more with Dr Oz Newt Gingrich
Senators Tim Scott and Tom Cotton we are
in York Pennsylvania thank you for being
with us
[Music]
[Applause]